[Musique]
le soleil se lève sur le sud de
l'Andalousie
[Musique]
juste à côté de l'autoroute des tranches
roulottes transit depuis plusieurs jours
[Musique]
parmi eux des dizaines de voyageurs
gitans il ne se connaissent pas mais ils
avancent tous dans la même direction
chaque année il parcourt des centaines
de kilomètres pour assister à une
cérémonie religieuse hors norme comme
ces hommes qui marchent pour s'infiger
une peine et expire leur péchés
ça fait trois jours que je marche on a
un peu d'eau fraîche un peu de
nourriture mais pas plus
[Musique]
ou à cheval tout s'avance vers ce petit
village d'Andalousie construit autour
d'une église
et d'un miracle
il y a 500 ans ici même la Vierge Marie
serait apparue à un bûcheron depuis sa
statue appelée le rossillo et vénéré
[Musique]
ce village porte son nom elle rossillot
on se croirait dans un western aucune
rue ne goudronnée elles sont en sable et
la ville ne compte que 1500 habitants
nous sommes le lundi de Pentecôte et
dans quelques heures un million de
fidèles inonderont les rues
des familles gitanes installe des
campements partout dans la ville
voici les miresses
pour cette fête religieuse la tradition
veut qu'il soit les plus élégants
possible
il faut toujours être sous son meilleur
jour il faut que les gens te voient
nickel ce pèlerinage est un sacrifice
ont chaque année
[Musique]
pour venir ici
c'est très cher
sur ce camp de fortune ils sont 30 de la
même famille gitane
[Musique]
vacances de l'année
la nuit tombe mais tout le monde doit
rester réveillé
car dans quelques instants le spectacle
va commencer
[Musique]
il est plus de minuit là dans chaque rue
des milliers d'hommes et de femmes
marchent au son des cloches et des
tambours
en deux heures le village perdu dans
dalousie se part d'une marée humaine
la vierge va bientôt sortir de l'église
[Musique]
cette gitane porte son effigie autour de
son cou cette médaille ne me quitte
jamais
on perd
quelques minutes plus tard les femmes et
les personnes âgées ont stoppé net leur
marche
à l'intérieur de l'église que des hommes
qui s'empoient tous veulent effleurer la
Vierge chaque année des centaines de
croyances ont écrasées par la foule
chacun veut sa part du miracle
[Applaudissements]
la procession va durer jusqu'à l'aube
dans la fièvre et la ferveur de cette
terre andalouse située à l'extrême sud
de l'Europe
c'est dans cette région que les
traditions espagnoles sont les plus
ancrées
c'est sur cette terre que les premiers
gitans sont arrivés en Europe il y a 600
ans
chez assez du Rajasthan en Inde ils ont
traversé l'Egypte pour arriver jusqu'en
Andalousie alors à l'époque on les
surnomme aux séries Thanos ce mot
deviendra plus tard gitanos en français
gitan
pour qu'il ne lui porte bonheur à moi et
à tous les gitans de l'univers on est là
et on restera longtemps ici rejeté
pendant des années ils l'ont acquis la
nationalité espagnole qu'en 1978
victimes de racisme il vivait alors dans
des ghettos
certains y habitent toujours et font
perdurer leur traditions secrètes et
archaïque
[Applaudissements]
sa virginité avec un mouchoir mais la
plupart des gitans ont lutté pour
s'intégrer
dans le monde entier où nous sommes nous
les gitans les mieux considérés
on a évolué on peut étudier on peut
travailler nous aussi c'est très
important pour se fondre dans cette
société espagnole si catholique ils se
sont convertis et sont devenus de
fervent croyant
chaque année il descendent dans les rues
pour les fêtes Saintes qu'il se
réapproprie avec des mesures au fil des
ans ils sont devenus puissants et
règnent sur les plus grandes
célébrations de la ville
aujourd'hui les gitans sont même à la
mode les riches andalouses portent leur
robes leur coiffure et dansent leur
flamenco les gitanes font rêver
je suis pas une gitane mais j'essaye de
danser comme elle j'aime dire que je
suis une gitane blanche
intégrée au Andalousie plus qu'ailleurs
les gitans sont fiers de garder leurs
racines et leurs valeurs la solidarité
le sens de la famille
le goût pour les fêtes extravagantes
avec beaucoup d'argent
et l'instinct pour les affaires sans
contrat à la parole de nez l'argent à
l'argent c'est pour ça qu'on vient dans
cette foire à l'occasion de la Semaine
sainte nous avons plongé dans
l'incroyable vie des gitans andalous
[Applaudissements]
la Sierra Nevada est la plus grande
montagne d'Andalousie
sur les hauteurs de grenades tout en
haut perché le palais de l'Alhambra
construit par les Arabes et terminé par
Charles Quint à protéger toute l'Europe
des invasions
juste en face une montagne sacrée
baptisée sacrementée
c'est ici que les premiers gitans sont
arrivés autour du 15e siècle
ils ont creusé la roche pour vivre dans
des grottes ici il savait qu'ils étaient
protégés
siècle plus tard ils sont toujours là
Kuro est le plus ancien de village
il est né dans cette grotte il n'en est
jamais parti
[Musique]
c'est la croix on allumait des petits
feux dans les grottes pour cuisiner
ni de salle de bain pas d'eau courante
voici à quoi ressemblait le quartier
dans les années 60
[Musique]
ils sont 4000 gitans à vivre sur la
montagne ce sont alors des parias les
pères de famille sont forgeron d'autres
fabriquent des paniers qu'ils vendent
dans la rue ils n'ont pas le droit à la
citoyenneté espagnole pas d'accès au
système de soins et les enfants n'ont
pas le droit à l'école et ceux jusqu'en
mais tous ont un talent inné qui va
changer le cours de leur existence
la danse
c'est cool ou qui a sublimé ce flamenco
[Musique]
et c'est en partie grâce à lui que les
gitans se sont intégrés à la population
locale
il a fait des grottes une curiosité pour
attirer les touristes et les
personnalités
[Musique]
qui sont venus il y a bill Clinton il y
a eu Michel Obama
le prix Nobel koffier Hanane il y avait
des grandes fêtes aussi avec des rois
il voulait même se marier avec les
gitanes le roi du Maroc a voulu se
marier avec l'une d'elles mais les
gitans dit non
les gitane ne se marie pas avec les rois
mais avec des gitans
il a créé un mystère et une fascination
autour de sa communauté
[Musique]
la nuit est tombée et comme chaque soir
des centaines de touristes font la queue
devant les grottes
[Musique]
ont pécheur pour voir les gitanes danser
50 euros la demi-heure de flamenco car
ce flamenco gitan ne se voit nulle part
ailleurs en Espagne on l'appelle la
Zambra un flamenco très rythmé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et soudain beaucoup plus lent
aujourd'hui dans la communauté les
femmes ont pris le pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
elles sont devenues propriétaires des
grandes ancestrales du sacrum monté
comme celle de Rosa et de sa sœur
Christina
qui chante ce sont les femmes pas les
hommes les gitans ont une mentalité
machiste ils l'ont oui mais ce sont les
femmes qui commandent se sont elles qui
gèrent le foyer qui ramène l'argent
elles en font plus que les hommes mon
mari est toujours près de moi mais ici
celle qui commence c'est moi si on n'est
pas là rien ne fonctionne
Rosa s'est construit une maison
au-dessus de sa grotte pour faire
perdurer son business elle prépare la
relève sa petite fille allez
une écolière de 9 ans
ma petite fille c'est la plus belle
tu vas être une magnifique artiste
tu chantes tu danses tu sais tout faire
n'est-ce pas
la petite fille n'a pas d'autre choix
que de consacrer son temps libre à
danser dans la grotte
je sais chanter je sais bouger et la
flamenca comme ça
très douée et c'est vrai que je suis
très douée dans notre famille la danse
vient de génération très ancienne et ça
continue toujours avec elle regarde les
expressions du visage qu'elle a ça c'est
elle toute seule je lui ai jamais montré
je mets la main comme ça puis un bisou
et je m'en vais
allez venez venez installez-vous vous
voulez pour l'avoir danser c'est
touristes ne paieront que quelques
boissons
car Sandra n'est pas encore une
professionnelle
[Applaudissements]
tu as vu comment elle bouge comment ça
va
pour son jeune âge
[Musique]
grâce à Laura les gitans gagnent
aujourd'hui leur vie mais ils se
souviennent sûrement qu'ils ont
longtemps été rejetés
alors pour garder leur indépendance loin
des villes et des touristes ils se
retrouvent entre eux et font des
affaires à leur manière avec leur code
et leur rites ancestraux
il faut apparent ils viennent vendre
leurs trésors
[Musique]
les chevaux sauvages
il va sauver bien le récupérer ce sont
les plus rares et les plus chers
d'Espagne entre 3000 et 20000 euros
l'animal
[Musique]
ici pas de contrat chez les gitans les
affaires se font à la parole donnée et
ça va très très vite
c'est bon 1500 allez dis oui mais non
mais non mais non mais non
1400 accède tu acceptes
cède
mais allez cède 1300
c'est un monde d'homme
la corde se conclut toujours par une
poignée de main et là encore les
familles gitanes veulent assurer la
relève transmettre leur savoir-faire à
leurs enfants est essentiel
Fendi est un jeune garçon gitan qui
vient là depuis qu'il est né
son père l'a initié aujourd'hui il va
lui montrer si il est capable ou non de
vendre des chevaux pour se donner du
courage il est venu avec sa très jeune
fiancée je m'appelle Fendi
père de Fendi est un puissant marchand
de chevaux
c'est notre chef à tous le patriarche le
patron le patron faut avoir l’œil
faut pas se faire avoir avec le prix du
chevalier
mon grand-père était négociant mon père
puis moi puis je passerai le rôle à mon
fils
oui je continue la tradition de mon père
voici les chevaux que doit vendre Fendi
des albinos
chez les gitans on dit qu'il porte
chance
[Musique]
un premier acheteur se présente
celui-ci me plaît plus que celui-là bien
sûr lui c'est le meilleur que j'ai
on commence à 4000
non non c'est un super cheval je l'ai
même pas proposé à mon père pour te le
réserver et toi fils tu en penses quoi
tu en veux combien papa
6000 euros mon fils
vous m'écoutez sinon chacun rentre chez
soi tu as dit 4000 et lui 6000 alors
avec respect et joie on se met d'accord
sur 5500 euros
non non
bon j'ai compris je t'emmène 5000 et
c'est fait on en parle plus
la
comice pays il est comme son père tel
père tel fils
Fendi a réussi sa vente en quelques
minutes il vient d'être admis au sein du
cercle très fermé des vendeurs de
chevaux gitans
ça a été une bonne vente dieu merci
et je vais en vendre d'autres si je peux
et ici c'est au tour d'un verre que
s'échange l'argent
[Musique]
te paye en cache avec des liasses de
billets
allez donne-moi l'argent de mes deux
chevaux
[Musique]
l'argent
cette fois
il dit ça mais moi j'en ai gagné
beaucoup plus
[Applaudissements]
la plupart de ces chevaux promènent les
touristes à Séville
la capitale de l'Andalousie est visitée
chaque année par 21 millions de
personnes
cette région du Sud est le moteur du
tourisme en Espagne
les gitans le savent il possède le
business des Kalash
un petit tour de la ville coûte environ
50 euros
ce business fait vivre une centaine de
familles
chaque année dès la fin avril leur
calèche envahissent Séville lors de
l'une des fêtes les plus somptueuses de
toutes l'Espagne la feria des avril
[Musique]
elle attire 4 millions de visiteurs avec
un costume traditionnel très prisé la
robe sévillane à froufrou un vêtement
d'inspiration gitane
notre
région totalement espagnol
il suit la mode c'est une robe cher très
cher
elle coûte entre 300 et 600 euros la
robe
après avoir été tant dénigré les gitans
sont à la mode
il y a 150 ans la feria s'était leur
foire aux bestiaux
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il ne règne plus sur la fête
mais leur Storm sont toujours là
les Fernandez sont une famille de gitans
sébiants
installez-vous chaque année ils viennent
y vendre leur beignets
[Musique]
s'il te plaît la musique super
ça va comment ça se passe ici
et on va refaire de la pâte
faut qu'elle lève parce que cette pâte
là elle a bien monté elle est parfaite
regarde comme elle est il est fou
et regarde vous allez voir le chocolat
et je vais mettre du sucre pour qu'il
soit bon
les gens aiment bien avoir la vie douce
comme le chocolat
les beignets on les fait comme ça
regarde tout est fait à la main
on fait ça depuis plus de 50 ans
il coûte 12 euros
on adore les beignets
prépare elles sont belles bien habillées
tout est très beau c'est une tradition
surtout c'est la tradition c'est
beignets font vivre les 30 membres du
clan ils en vendent 8000 par semaine et
la famille gagne de quoi vivre pendant
un an
alors ils ne font pas la fête mais
travaille beaucoup
on commence à 16h le soir et ça ne
s'arrête pas jusqu'à 7 heures du matin
le stand est encore ouvert ça ne
s'arrête jamais
c'est une semaine intense très
importante mais on est heureux car on
ramène beaucoup d'argent à la maison
oui je vais te la présenter
maman viens là
[Musique]
c'est elle qui garde notre argent c'est
elle qui commande depuis toujours c'est
la meilleure un phénomène c'est de moi
que tu parles
de toi tu es la meilleure
Mamadou Laurette gère l'argent c'est
elle aussi qui distribue le salaire à
chaque membre de sa famille
j'ai que ça c'est ça ou rien
mais si regarde tu en as plein allez
prends ça
à 79 ans elle a toujours travaillé ici
j'ai commencé avec un tout petit stand
c'était dur à l'époque
le terrain était mauvais mais je me suis
accrochée
et puis j'ai eu beaucoup de succès et
c'est moi qui est formé toute la famille
parce que le bon Dieu il m'a donné ce
don pour entreprendre et maintenant j'ai
tout ça
si la petite entreprise de Mama Dolores
c'est devenu aussi lucrative c'est parce
que les millions de visiteurs y
dépensent sans compter
là où société espagnole se retrouve dans
ces cassettes pendant une semaine
nuit et jour ils font la fête à la façon
gitane
[Musique]
toujours bondés
ou inviter sa famille et ses amis
[Musique]
mais pour cela il faut payer très cher
car louer un stand pendant une semaine
peut coûter jusqu'à 100 000 euros
la feria c'est la fête de l'année ou le
plus d'argent assez vie circulent et
dépensent sont énormes chaque soir tu
flammes beaucoup d'argent on boit on
offre beaucoup de bouteilles on mange
après pendant 2 mois on mange des
sandwichs on a plus de problèmes mais
maintenant on dépense tout notre argent
et après si on a plus rien ces prochains
mois plus d'argent tu trouves ce que tu
peux trouver
[Applaudissements]
être déraisonnable c'est le mot d'ordre
de cette feria au point de faire évoluer
les mentalités aujourd'hui les Espagnols
rêvent même d'avoir un peu de sang gitan
et je veux danser à la manière des
gitans je ne suis pas gitane mais
j'essaye de danser comme elle alors
évidemment les gitans ils sont
j'arriverai jamais à leur niveau mais
j'adore comment ils dansent ils ont ça
dans le sang
[Applaudissements]
si le temps de la feria les gitans sont
à l'honneur d'autres n'ont pas su ce
fondre dans la société espagnole
à 10 minutes de là dans la banlieue sud
de Séville des gitans vivent dans une
extrême pauvreté
voici les 3000 un ghetto d'une centaine
de familles gitanes
nous sommes dans le quartier le plus
pauvre d'Espagne le taux de chômage y
est le plus élevé du pays
on est des animaux ou quoi
on a des droits à nous aussi
[Musique]
les immeubles sont délabrés
les poubelles ne sont plus ramassées
tous
même les plus jeunes sont livrés à
eux-mêmes
[Musique]
que vous filmez
dans ce quartier dangereux les enfants
montent la garde avec des armes en
plastique
depuis deux mois la plupart des
habitants vivent sans électricité un
générateur a brûlé
aucun service de l'État ne s'aventure
pour le réparer les premières victimes
de cette situation ce sont les enfants
ils servent à nous brancher à
l'électricité on en a plus chez nous il
faut qu'il remette l'électricité
on peut pas aller à l'école parce qu'on
peut plus se laver on n'a pas de
vêtements propres
on peut pas regarder la télé on n'a pas
internet
c'est triste que les enfants ne puissent
plus aller à l'école
partout dans le quartier des dizaines de
câbles suspendus entre les immeubles un
système D comme chez cette mère de
famille la voisine me tend un câble
jusqu'ici je le branche chez moi et j'ai
de l'électricité dans la maison c'est
mon ami qui m'aide elle m'a dit Sonia
achète un câble je vais te rendre
service pour tes enfants
tu le branches au mur et après tu as de
l'électricité partout dans la maison
il ne reste plus que la solidarité entre
voisins
les enfants
[Musique]
on en a marre de tout ça
les habitants sont excédés et refusent
aujourd'hui de payer leur loyer
Ramon habite ici depuis plus de 40 ans
ça c'est la conséquence de l'abandon de
notre bailleur c'est lui qui nous loue
ses appartements et qui devrait
s'assurer de l'entretien de nos
immeubles
mais regarde ça fait des années qui ne
passe plus ici
[Musique]
non plus il y a plus d'électricité on
est dans le noir même pour les
ascenseurs
[Musique]
pourtant ils ne viennent pas réparer
venez je vais vous montrer chez moi
[Musique]
on m'a donné un peu de nourriture et
comme vous voyez il n'y a plus de
courant
dans ce bâtiment
vivent trop de familles
[Musique]
on peut rentrer
oui oui
j'ai plus préparé quelques saucisses
pour les enfants et un peu de frites que
je viens de cuisiner
parce que sans électricité je ne peux
pas allumer mes plaques vitrocéramiques
j'ai besoin de courant pour cuisiner
on a que la bonbonne de gaz comme au
camping
sans électricité les tâches du quotidien
sont devenues compliquées
nous subissons une grave discrimination
et depuis longtemps
vu les conditions dans lesquelles nous
vivons le manque d'électricité aggrave
notre situation on voit bien aujourd'hui
nous sommes abandonnés pourtant malgré
cette grande précarité les traditions
gitanes doivent perdurer
même les plus coûteuses
à quelques rues de là dans ce quartier
modeste mais moins délabré va se tenir
l'un des événements les plus importants
dans la vie d'un gitan son mariage
c'est mon cadet
tout pour leurs enfants c'est beaucoup
de travail c'est tout pour leurs enfants
Abraham a 17 ans ses parents comme ceux
de la future mariée son vendeur
ambulance et de sacs dans la cuisine
vous les mettez tout en haut OK
cela fait un an qu'ils économisent pour
payer ses noces elles ont coûté 30000
euros
pour un gitan même pauvre un mariage
doit être spectaculaire c'est le respect
et l'honneur de la famille qui sont en
jeu
pour les mariés
quand même s'ils ont investi une grande
partie de leurs économies ils n'ont pas
pu s'offrir de traiteurs
alors c'est toute la famille qui se met
au fourneau
bonsoir à toi
lui lui et il en manque encore d'autres
ils vont cuisiner
de grosses quantités sont à prévoir car
c'est les gitans il n'y a pas
d'invitation tout le monde peut venir à
la fête
dans la cuisine les femmes du clan
attendent ce moment depuis très
longtemps
c'est ma mère et là ma belle-mère
c'est ma première fille qui se marie
je suis très émue
parce qu'elle va nous donner voilà
quelque chose de très spécial pour les
gitans
et on est très fier de ma fille
pendant le mariage une cérémonie très
spéciale est très archaïque va se
dérouler son but vérifier si la jeune
fille est bien vierge
c'est important de la cérémonie du
mouchoir c'est notre honneur
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
appelle la mettre un terme à cette
épreuve
mais les jeunes gitaniciennes
vive nos coutumes elles sont si belles
elles ne se perdront jamais
[Applaudissements]
dans 24 heures ces deux familles vont
sceller une union pour la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le lendemain tout le quartier est réuni
devant l'immeuble de la mariée
elle arrive
elle s'appelle Neria elle n'a que 15 ans
elle est encore au collège
ce sont ses parents qui ont payé sa robe
cet adolescente qui trace sa famille ce
soir les enfants gitans ne partent de
chez leurs parents que lorsqu'ils se
marient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son père Ismaël est très fier
c'est ma petite fille c'est le soleil de
ma maison
et tout le monde doit être heureux il
faut boire il faut en profiter c'est
seulement un jour dans la vie elle ne se
mariera jamais après c'est pour toute la
vie près de 500 invités doivent assister
au mariage mais beaucoup ne sont pas
encore là
pour qu'elle vienne
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait faut qu'elle
arrive maintenant on ne peut pas
attendre
[Applaudissements]
de sa famille
comme un dernier adieu
dans l'immeuble d'en face vit à Bram son
futur mari
lui aussi est entouré par ses proches
elle s'embrassera chaque personne de ma
famille doit m'habiller quelqu'un me met
mes chaussures quelqu'un d'autre ma
chemise cette tradition gitane est
réputée portée bonheur aux mariés
tu es beau
une dernière danse
[Applaudissements]
un dernier baiser d'une mère pour son
fils
bien marié ses enfants c'est aussi se
faire respecter aux yeux de la
communauté pour l'occasion les familles
ont vu les choses en grand
[Musique]
reçoit ses derniers cadeaux
en bas tout le quartier attend les
mariés
la mariée
magnifique ma belle-fille
[Applaudissements]
les deux adolescents se connaissent
depuis qu'ils sont nés
Abraham a demandé n'est rien en mariage
il y a un an elle avait alors 14 ans
[Applaudissements]
écoute tranquille tu souris ma robe
n'arrête pas de descendre c'est rien ne
t'inquiète pas on va arranger ça
[Applaudissements]
profite de ton père ma fille tu es
l'unique n'oublie pas que c'est le jour
de ta vie il n'y en aura pas d'autres
ce mariage est un mariage de luxe pour
ses familles modestes
alors il faut que tous le voient
[Applaudissements]
tout va bien on est heureux
[Musique]
le mariage va se dérouler dans une salle
des fêtes tout va commencer par une
cérémonie religieuse
néréa et Abraham sont chrétiens
évangélique comme plus d'un quart des
gitans espagnols à partir d'aujourd'hui
messieurs dames ils vont fonder une
famille leurs propres foyers ce sont des
pasteurs gitans qui les bénissent
les seigneurs et faites qu'ils aient
beaucoup d'enfants
sont maintenant considérés comme un
couple aux yeux de la communauté
[Musique]
dans mon art c'est une princesse c'est
la plus belle
la robe blanche de la mariée c'est le
symbole de la pureté
ils sont nerveux des vêtements sont
inconfortables la couronne mais il faut
supporter
au poids de la couronne
la fête commence la peine mais trop
d'invités sont venus
[Musique]
il n'y a pas assez de place pour tout le
monde
on est déjà 500 personnes mais d'autres
gens vont arriver c'est ça qui me
préoccupe
les familles gitanes sont nombreuses
les cousins arrivent de toutes l'Espagne
[Musique]
toutes les femmes portent leurs plus
belles robes
[Musique]
leur plus belle parure
tous danse avec les mariés au son d'un
orchestre gitan
[Musique]
tout s'attendre le gâteau
il est presque deux heures du matin
lorsqu'il arrive enfin
pour en avoir une part il faut donner un
billet
c'est une jarretière à la gitane
on va préparer avec les femmes la
cérémonie du mouchoir
car pour que le mariage soit totalement
cédé il manque encore un rituel la
cérémonie du mouchoir une tradition
séculaire secrète
on pourrait mettre la table au centre
pour que les anciennes se mettent ici
Neria va devoir s'allonger sur cette
table et prouver sa virginité
la mariée sera ici avec un mouchoir elle
va prouver qu'elle est vierge ensuite le
mouchoir sera montré à la foule c'est
une aroutadora qui le fait dans la
tradition de génération en génération sa
mère par exemple à tester ma virginité
si
les petites finesses on les éduque ainsi
elles peuvent donner leur honneur
alors elles font attention elle ne
peuvent pas avoir de petits copains
avant leur mariage
c'est une gitane réputée pour sa sagesse
dans quelques instants à la manière
d'une gynécologue elle va vérifier si
l'hymen de néréa est intacte ce rite
gitan date d'un autre temps
[Musique]
cinerea n'est pas vierge elle fera la
honte de sa famille et ne pourra pas se
marier dans le machisme de la communauté
gitane l'honneur des familles repose sur
la douleur des femmes la jeune fille
redoute cette cérémonie incontournable
mais elle ne la fait pas contre son gré
elle veut prouver ce que les gitans
appellent la pureté la route adora la
rassure et lui prodigue ces derniers
conseils
les hommes eux n'ont rien à prouver du
tout ils attendent dehors et la
cérémonie c'est maintenant
je ne veux que les gitans nager et la
famille des mariés d'accord et les
autres vous êtes en cercle derrière elle
les femmes âgées ici les caméras dehors
la vérification de l'hymen ne dure que
quelques minutes
[Musique]
néréa est maintenant officiellement
marié
[Applaudissements]
en signe de respect son père et son
grand-père laillent sur leur dos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour leur porte chance les invités
jettent des kilos de dragées
ce mouchoir appartient maintenant à la
belle-mère de néréa elle le brandit tel
un trophée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est près de 5 heures du matin
néréa peut enfin souffler
[Applaudissements]
Abraham lui et félicité par les hommes
pour la virginité de sa femme
[Applaudissements]
était sublime elle a fait vraiment
honneur à sa famille c'était magnifique
très beau tout était parfait elle sait
très bien comporté je suis heureuse et
très fière
et qu'est-ce que tu vas faire maintenant
dans notre maison on sera toujours
ensemble c'est comme ça chez nous
chez les gitans espagnols plus
qu'ailleurs les règles sont strictes le
divorce est interdit dès la fin de la
cérémonie le couple s'installera dans un
appartement dans le quartier de leur
enfance
les jeunes gitans s'éloignera rarement
de leurs parents
il y a six siècles alors arrivé dans le
pays les gitans ne priait aucun Dieu
mais pour mieux s'intégrer ils ont
embrassé les croyances des Espagnols
pour devenir de fervent catholique ils
ont mis près de 400 ans à obtenir le
Saint Graal avoir l'honneur de
participer au procession de la plus
grande fête religieuse de l'année celle
de la semaine sainte
ils ont même fondé leur propre confrérie
aujourd'hui on vient du monde entier
pour les voir
dans un quartier populaire au nord de
Séville
Antonio 35 ans se prépare un grand jour
ouvrit dans une usine de carton il n'est
pas encore marié
toute sa vie est dédiée à la religion
sur son lit un costume
il appartient à la mystérieuse confrérie
catholique des gitans
la dévotion c'est ça le plus important
pour moi
toutes les confréries ont leur propre
idole et moi j'ai toujours fait partie
de celle des gitans et je serai toujours
parmi eux
est enfant quand il est entré dans cette
fraternité
à suivre ce chemin spécial
devenir un frère chez les gitans et là
c'est lui
c'est la traduction depuis notre
naissance
que j'ai choisi à l'âge adulte mais je
suis ainsi depuis que je suis tout petit
lui et ce qu'on appelle durant la
semaine sainte un Nazaréen
c'est-à-dire un pénitent
ce costume est celui que portait les
condamnés à mort pendant l'acquisition
espagnole
je prépare la cagoule qui recouvre la
tête et le visage et les épaules et je
mets ce cône à l'intérieur
de la maison à l'église n'est pas le
droit de montrer mon visage quand je
suis à vue des passants je dois le
cacher
une expérience qu'on partage en famille
là ma tante m'aide à m'habiller
et les boutons aussi
et ça nous unit un peu plus
les prochaines heures s'annoncent
éprouvantes pour Antonio désormais
pénitent il doit se cacher n'a plus le
droit de parler manger ou boire pendant
près de 15 heures
le temps que va durer la procession
[Musique]
la nuit tombe sur ses villes
c'est l'heure pour Antonio de rejoindre
l'église des gitans
comme lui les pénitents arrivent les uns
après les autres ils sont près d'un
millier là ils sont entre eux et peuvent
retirer leur cagoule
seuls les plus pratiquants sont élus
pour participer à ce rituel
[Musique]
il y a des femmes des hommes et même des
enfants
où habitait par la foi
la cérémonie va commencer Antonio doit
remettre sa cagoule qu'il devra garder
jusqu'à la fin de la procession
le public n'est pas autorisé à assister
à ces moments d'intimité au cœur de
l'église
voici les causes saléros ce sont des
porteurs des hommes qu'on ne voit jamais
ce sont aussi les fidèles les plus
costauds dans quelques instants ils vont
soulever sur leur nuxés
le trou des construit sur une planche
avec des tasseaux qu'on place ici pour
la portée sur la nuque
puis on met ce linge très serré sur
notre tête
on renforce cette partie car elle nous
sert aussi à porter il faut bien serrer
intense au cou qu'il y a un moment où on
ne sent plus rien dans notre corps
le 32 à se glisser sous chaque trône ils
vont fournir un effort hors du commun 40
kg rien que sur leur nuque
vous êtes courageux
jusqu'à la mort
pour lui
ces hommes vont rester pendant 16 heures
sous le poids du Christ et de la Vierge
des gitans
[Musique]
cette nuit c'est tout l'Andalousie qui
vibre de cérémonie Saintes
[Musique]
au même moment
à Grenade
dans le village troglodyte berceau des
gitans la même ferveur
mais ici on chante l'âne des gitans des
champs puissants au balcon que l'on
appelle les saitas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là il crie la fierté de leurs origines
et l'héroïsme des porteurs épuisés qui
marchaient depuis l'aube
la procession est terminée et ce soir
les gitans ouvrent leur cave aux riches
andalous
il les invitent à célébrer la Vierge
leur offre à boire et à manger
[Musique]
et pourtant j'habite à Grenade je
connaissais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
censéro côté digitales un privilège pour
ces femmes espagnoles
[Musique]
pour les gitans ces fêtes sont une façon
de s'intégrer encore un peu plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le lendemain matin à Séville
la procession gitane se poursuit
[Musique]
les infatigables caussent les roses
portent la Vierge à bout de nuque depuis
plus de 16 heures
[Musique]
les plus jeunes pénitences sont épuisés
c'était un peu long
moi j'ai marché pendant 7 heures
de participe depuis que je suis toute
petite à la semaine sainte
[Musique]
la Vierge des gitans a fait le tour de
la ville elle retourne à son église
depuis près de 50 ans c'est aussi grâce
à elle que la communauté gitane rayonne
les coussins les roses peuvent enfin se
reposer et s'hydrater
chaque année ils sont plus nombreux
parmi les gitans à vouloir s'infliger
cette épreuve
c'était finalement assez court mais
vraiment bien après 16h on a quelques
douleurs mais ça va quand tu fais
quelque chose que tu aimes tu n'as pas
mal je suis très heureux et en même
temps triste que ce soit fini jusqu'à
l'année prochaine
cette semaine sainte a rassemblé plus de
2 millions de fidèles à Séville
avec leur vie de secret et le rare de
l'émotion
les incroyables gitans poursuivent sans
relâche leur fusion andalouse
[Applaudissements]